you guys have a lot of chemistry where
you did you know each other beforehand
or were you aware of each other all the
chemistry in the film is just acting
yeah can't stand him I don't know maybe
it's like the Kiwi Australian thing yeah
it kind of felt like we already had
known each other when we face working
from an Lee's yeah
were you a fan of Riverdale and were you
a fan of the Fosters yeah I definitely
seen a couple episodes of the FASTA so I
knew I knew my I knew what I was getting
into we both knew exactly what we were
doing yeah could you even okay you guys
grew up as actors could you relate to
the whole teen experience of high school
and graduating and that I actually
couldn't at all um my kind of high
school experience was unconventional
like I was shooting a lot I'm walking
half the time so I kind of had one foot
already in that door I didn't graduate
high school I didn't go to college I
just started working so um yeah it
couldn't relate but I know a lot of
people can so um it was fun I mean
that's part of like playing a character
could you relate to it Katie
I'm pretty much in a similar boat to
Maya I didn't graduate high school
either I was working while I was in high
school so I kind of already figured out
this is what I wanted to do this is what
I was gonna go for so you didn't miss
any of that angst when oh there was ink
I was still angst and I definitely saw
it around me like people making those
decisions yeah and like having those
discussions with friends and stuff but I
think I don't know I feel lucky that I
had knew what I was wanted to do yeah at
a young age now this film romance what's
the most romantic thing that you have
done in your own lives for a significant
other mmm I kind of give that secret
away can i oh come on
nah that's happening that's not
happening
I'm I don't think I've done like a grand
gesture but I'll do like just trying you
know a little cute surprises and stuff
I've done something some pretty good
stuff but I kind of give away my secrets
uh-huh otherwise somebody might take off
and that wouldn't be as romantic
what is your summer wish list for 2019
hmm I like to take a vacation that would
be nice but you know I also want to work
so yeah we'll see my family's from
salmaah I would love to get back to Sawa
I used to go there a lot as a kid so it
would be amazing to go back there for
the summer so tell me about the working
on this film a very fun part of it was
the outtakes at the end so while you
were making it were you oh it looks like
you had fun
from the outtakes it looks like it yeah
we had a lot of fun yeah did you grow up
with like having bonfires and all that
kind of stuff and yeah yeah I'm from a
super small town so growing up we kind
of had to make our own fun
so it was a lot of like bonfires and
like we'd find a kid in school that had
like a paddock somewhere and we'd like
go run amok there and like crashing out
cause and stuff so like there was a lot
of outdoors it's a different vibe in
Australia and New Zealand for sure yeah
it's a full different vibe yeah what do
you hope people take away from this
movie teens in particular I would guess
I think to not rush making those kind of
decisions what you want to do for the
rest of your life yeah and just stay
true to yourself and and to follow you
what you're passionate about did
you